Spacey was acquitted of all nine charges
related to sexual offense the celebrated
oscar-winning actor Kevin Spacey
initially faced 12 charges when the
trial commenced at London Southward
Crown Court three of these charges were
dropped during trial the charges which
included seven counts of sexual assault
were made by four men claiming the
incidents occurred between 2001 and
2013. Kevin Spacey endured false
accusations that shattered his life and
led to his removal from the Hollywood
scene ultimately after many years he was
found not guilty however the questions
arise will he be able to reclaim that
time and money lost during this ordeal